>>Teacher: I want to quickly
just recap this school year.
Can anyone think of some of
the things that we had to deal
with as a trailblazer
family this school year?
>>Student: Ike.
>>Teacher: Hurricane Ike.
Blew the-- came and blew the
roof off of our building.
On top of Ike, anything else happen?
>>Student: Swine flu.
>>Teacher: Swine flu, yes.
And I know a lot of you have had
some tough stuff go on personally.
Who's gone through personal stuff
this year that's been really tough
for them.
Almost all of us.
It's been a challenging year, and
while we could have made excuses,
day in and day out, no one did.
And the good news is that our
scores came back stronger than ever,
and so for the sixth year in a row,
we will be an exemplary
campus next year
>>All: [cheering]
>>Craig: Our students are here
because they're on a mission.
They know their ultimate goal,
at the end of the day, is,
they need to be better
preparing themselves for college,
and not just going to college,
but completing college as well.
>>Rachel: Romeo has not received
the letter yet from Friar Lawrence.
Talk about that with your table.
What are the--
>>Chris: You've got to have a
great teacher in every classroom,
and the rest of the stuff is great,
you know, computers and stuff,
and things, that's all dandy, but
if you don't have a great teacher
in the classroom, it
doesn't really matter.
>>Erick: So the pressure
launches this out.
By changing the angle in the
equation, before we shoot it,
we're able to calculate
how far it's going to go.
>>Michelle: We're a project based
school, so the students are asked
to do things that are going to really
challenge them to think critically.
It excites them, so they
always talk about projects,
and they're really
excited to do them,
because of those relevant
connections.
>>Katie: So if the moon
is going to be right here,
remember that we're going
to look in a straight line.
>>I think we've learned that
kids love it when we integrate.
They see the connections
a lot more quickly
than I think we ever
thought they would.
And they sort of latch
onto that information.
>>Mark: We want to be preparing
students to be highly successful,
and part of the way we do that is
introducing them to long hours.
So our school day is from 7:30
until 4:30, Monday through Friday.
That's a 45 hour work week.
You know, just getting more time in
front of the students, teaching them,
having them work on projects,
more time, we believe,
is positively correlated
with better results.
>>Philip: This is a small
example of what's going to happen
for the rest of your life.
If you make poor decisions,
you're going to miss
out on the great opportunities.
>>I think, kind of the approach
with the students is that, look,
I care about you tremendously, I
really want you to be successful,
I'm not giving up on you.
But you've let me down, and
you've let your classmates down,
you've let your teachers down,
but each day is a new day
to hold themselves responsible for
their behaviors, and that they,
with their actions, can get
back into the community,
and be a part of the family again.
>>Man: Oh, come in, please, Sir.
>>Bryan: I think the home
visit does a number of things.
At first, it's that direct personal
contact we can have with the parents,
and I think it's a nice personal
touch that kind of sets the mood
for the fact that we are
a family oriented school.
We're not only willing to say
it, but we're willing to kind
of put our money where our mouth is.
>>Chris: The contract, I
think is, it's symbolic,
but what we want parents
to understand is
that this has got to
be a team effort.
You know, this is a
three legged stool.
It's us, it's your kid, and it's
you, and if we work together
for the next seven years, your
kid is going to be able to go
to any college they want to.
>>Bryan: Sign under the
Student Signature, please?
>>Rachel: The students know the
expectations, and they recognize
that they need this education to get
to the place that they want to go to.
They love being in an environment
where they have teachers who care
about them and care about their
success, and they feed off of that.
So when you walk into a classroom,
you will see students, you know,
engaged, and participating
and whatnot, because they know
that this is their
ticket to something great.
>>Nelson: Good afternoon, my name
is Nelson Mendoza, and this fall,
I will be attending, Yale University.
>>All: [cheering, applause]
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.